renault aimerait savoir d'où vient
l'expression être le dindon de la farce
personne n'a envie d'être le dindon de
la farce nevoux renan ni moins car cela
signifie que l'on est la victime d'une
mauvaise plaisanterie et que les autres
se moquent de nous cette expression date
de la fin du xviiie siècle mais trouve
son origine dans des comédies du moyen
âge quand on appelait alors des farces
il y avait souvent un homme un peu bêtes
que les autres tournaient en ridicule il
était représenté par un da dont un
animal qui avait la réputation d'être
bête le nano lui est une espèce rapporté
d'amérique par les conquistadors au 16e
siècle en tout cas cette mauvaise image
est resté collé à la peau du dindon
tenait en 1896 un auteur célèbre georges
feydeau a popularisé l'expression en
donnant le titre le dindon à une de ses
pièces comiques et tout le monde a
gloussé de rire